hey guys
welcome to this video on youtube ideas
for 2021.
youtube is the social media platform
that needs no introduction
launched back in the year 2005 youtube
was a fresh breath of air for the people
who were slowly becoming aware of the
hype that surrounded the internet
several other platforms like dailymotion
with me and vmo
which admittedly have their own fans
have tried to stand up against the
vehement
that is the youtube and failed slowly
but surely marketers began to realize
the enormous potential that youtube
offered
they could add small advertisements like
they do in the cable tv they could show
banner ads and do much more and all the
thanks to the robust advertisement
features
that google already offered if you're
not already sold on why
it's important to advertise on youtube
here are some facts that might change
your mind
youtube has more than 2 billion users
across the world
a good fraction of that audience could
be shown your product
and could turn from users to customers
next important fact is that
8 out of 10 marketers consider youtube
to be one of the best platforms
to advertise their products and services
followed by that
people watch one billionaires of youtube
per day
as you watch this video you are
contributing to that number
next 62 percent of the business use
youtube
to post content this could be just
videos on their products
tutorials event announcements and much
more
seventy percent of the youtube watch
time comes from mobile
this means that when you create an
advertisement for youtube
you keep the mobile users in your mind
and
finally ninety percent of the people say
that they've discovered new products
or brands on youtube which means that by
posting on youtube your brand awareness
is highly likely to increase
now let's talk about the video ideas
the first one is behind the scene videos
these videos give you the opportunity to
showcase your audience
how your business or brand operates a
creatively made video on the inner
workings of your business
will show off a more human side of your
brand and
make you more relatable to your audience
it is also guaranteed to get you loads
of views
and engagement here's an example how
amazon showcases the warehousing and
distribution aspects
of its products it takes the viewers
into the factories
and involves the various people working
there this shows to the audience that
even a large
organization like amazon how each
individual has an important role to play
in the overall process
next we have the company culture a video
that highlights your company culture
will tell the audience what your
business goals are what its values are
and why it exists it can also focus on
the various people who make sure
the company works in the way it does
this can help
better connect with your audience here's
an example
a company culture video created by
godaddy the popular domain register
the video talks about how godaddy
creates a fun inclusive and
energetic environment for its employees
it includes interviews of employees
talking about
why they enjoy working in godaddy so
much and
this helps the audience relate with the
company and could also catch up the
interest with some potential job seekers
next we have the third idea that is the
marketing team
a brand is nothing without the people
working behind it
and that's where these videos come in
these videos will help shine a light on
the people who create the products
that the audience knows and loves this
helps create a personal connection with
the audience
these individuals can end up becoming
mascots for your brand
here's an example of meet the team
focusing on olympus group
the video goes into the history of
mascot maker's brand
and the people that make it a grand
success the lighthearted tone of the
video also greatly helps
with making it more relatable now we
have
number four product showcase or
announcement
a product showcase video aims to show
the features and benefits of the brand's
latest offering to its audience
these short concise videos can inform
the audience about everything they need
to know about the new product or service
a product announcement video on the
other hand can be used to give the
audience
a more detailed look into the product or
service
than the product showcase it can include
comparisons to older versions or
competitors
the aim of such video is to show
customers how the new product works and
why they need it
now this video needs no introduction
apple's iphone videos have always been
short but smooth sleek and concise
representations
of what the product would be like next
at number 5
we have event announcements these videos
can build a hype regarding an upcoming
event
it will also give you the opportunity to
engage with your audience and build
their interest
this promo video for the data innovation
summit 2020 hypes up the event posting
the greatest minds in the tech the most
innovative companies
and much more the next video idea we
have at number six
is the explainer videos these videos are
aimed to tell users how a particular
product
or a service works these tend to be much
more useful than
wall of text explaining how something
works
they also have an added advantage of
simplifying complex concepts and
features
to your audience for example we have our
own video on digital marketing
we cover a number of different concepts
like seo
social media marketing search engine
marketing and more on a visual manner
making it more likely to grab the
attention of a viewer
next at number 7 we have tutorials
tutorial videos give users some
actionable insights
and knowledge that your users can learn
from
these videos aim to be guides to
information complex concepts
hints tips and tricks relating to your
industry
here we have our own digital marketing
course video as an example
unlike the previous example i mentioned
this video goes into much
more detail regarding each of the
concepts of digital marketing
on that note if you guys are interested
in learning about digital marketing
i suggest you start from this video it's
a great one to get started with
now on the next video idea at number 8
we have the product tutorial
a product tutorial video will take your
audience through the various features of
your product offers
alongside its intricacies it can also
detail some additional insights about
your product
you can also explain the best way the
product can be used
here is a video of how the meditation
app headspace explains the app's usage
with an interesting and creative
animated video
now let's go ahead with number nine at
the number nine
we have the webinar a webinar thanks to
its nature
provides your brand with lots of
opportunities to interact with your
audience
they are usually very accessible and
easy to make
they are also very cost effective and
can be reused as video content
after the session is complete here's an
example of simplylearn's webinar
where we talk to the industry experts
regarding wide variety of topics while
involving the audience
by having the guest answer the audience
questions
whenever possible next at number 10 we
have the live streams
live streams for an event will help
build excitement and hype for the event
it can be advertised on other social
media platforms
to generate some hype as well these
videos can also help you bring up your
product to a larger audience
and at a reduced cost here's an example
of a live stream that constantly keeps a
track of
subscribers increasing for some of the
most popular youtube channels
next at number 11 we have ama or
ask me anything sessions
the ama or ask me anything sessions are
usually
live streams or pre-recorded sessions
that feature questions collected from
the audience although it originated from
reddit
these videos are finding a success on
youtube thanks to the interactivity that
it offers
these sessions can also give your
audience the opportunity to interact
with you
provide suggestions feedback and much
more
here's an example of ama session with
the actor
matt damon where questions covering a
wide variety of topics collected from
reddit
were answered by him
next at number 12 we have interviews
interviewing someone interesting or of
an authority within your niche can go a
long way
to grow your audience these sessions are
doubly advantageous too
firstly you and by extension your
audience
get to interact with an industry
stalwart and since this video can be
shared on
your channel as well as theirs you can
expose your channel to a brand new
audience
here's an example of an interview
between marcus brownlee a popular tech
youtuber
with bill gates the interview covers a
wide variety of topics and maintains a
pleasant theme throughout
let's now go to number 13 testimonials
a testimonial video help highlight the
positive feedback from a client or a
customer
they provide social proof and provide a
unique perspective
on your products and services these
videos can greatly help improve people's
trust on your brand
shareability and credibility here's an
example of simply lunch testimonial
video that covers a learner's journey
as he grew in his career thanks to
simply learn certification
a video like this can be greatly
relatable to the audience and even
encourage some of them to take up a
certification
let's go to our next video idea that is
the number 14
whiteboard videos a whiteboard video
offers your visually attractive way of
explaining complex concepts
usually this involves a trained experts
breaking through
a complex topic on a whiteboard nowadays
there has also been the trend of digital
whiteboard videos
that work thanks to the visual style and
charisma of the narrator
here's an example of the whiteboard
video simply learn created covering
various concepts of social media
marketing with the help of an
engaging narrative and interesting
visuals next up we have
number 15 competitions competitions or
contest videos give your audience the
opportunity to get involved with your
channel
these videos enable you to generate
fresh and original content
with little from your end in an
interesting example
for foldable flight channel users
submitted their ideas for paper
airplanes that would go
to the farthest distance the channel
received a significant amount of
submissions
and saw considerable growth next we have
16 the lists list videos are some of the
most commonly found content on youtube
most users enjoy this type of content
thanks to it being small easily
digestible
and bite-sized these videos can cover a
wide range of topics
like options to choose from the best
products techniques
and much more the main advantage of
these videos are
they provide users with value while
further involving them with your channel
here's an example of a list that we have
created on the top 10 skills you need to
become a data analyst
in the year 2021 if you are interested
don't forget to check it out
at number 17 we have case studies case
studies talk about
how your product or service have
benefited clients
and users videos like this can greatly
improve relatability and making your
brand seem more likeable
here's a video that analyzes coca-cola's
marketing campaign and what it made
one of the most popular brands in the
world now
let's talk about content that may not be
necessarily for a brand
but for individual creators at number 18
we have
tech unboxing these videos usually
involve packages being open for the
first time
while these are fairly common for
technology these videos have also found
success in fashion apparel
these videos enable the users to
experience the products for the first
time
sometimes even helping them decide
between rival products
here's an example of ps5 being unboxed
by marcus brownlee
who goes into detail regarding each of
its console components controllers
and other specifications at number 19 we
have tech reviews
with tech reviews you can talk about the
various features of a particular product
what you liked about it what you did its
price and other practical information
and much more
here we have an example of oneplus 8 pro
being reviewed in detail covering its
many features
advantages disadvantages and much more
and finally we have number 20 reaction
videos
reaction videos are exactly what the
name says
you giving an emotional reaction to
something like a movie trailer
music video or tv episode these videos
encourage a large amount of engagement
from the audience and make your brand
seem more relatable
here's an example of a reaction video
involving teenagers
reacting to the latest tick-tock videos
these videos usually enable a large
amount of likes comments and shares
and there we go that's our list of
youtube ideas for 2021
here's your reminder to subscribe to our
channel and click on the bell icon
to stay updated on tutorials live
sessions and
latest technologies and with that we
have reached the end of this video
i hope you found this informative and
helpful thank you for watching
and stay tuned for more from simply
learn
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified click here